this video is currently sponsored by
millernote find out more later on hey 42
here every so often a tv show comes
along that somehow manages to extend its
influence beyond our living rooms and
out into the real world game of thrones
turned millions of unsuspecting normals
into die-hard fantasy geeks
in the 1930s popeye caused a 33 rise in
spinach consumption in the us
and breaking bad saw crystal nephew
skyrocket all over the world peaky
blinders on the other hand convinced an
entire generation of young british men
to get funny haircuts and blow their
life savings on tweed but it isn't only
in the world of fashion where you can
see the peaky blind of effect the show
has spawned countless themed pubs and
nightclubs and in 2019 there was even a
fully fledged peaky blinders festival
headlined by the likes of liam gallagher
and primal screen
tourism in birmingham not exactly a
traditional highlight of the trip to the
uk
is up 26
since the show first aired in 2013 and
there's been an across a board boost in
the popularity of children's names like
tommy arthur and ada
whether or not you've actually watched
peaky blinders there's a very good
chance you've heard of it it's won
multiple awards and brought in millions
of viewers from all over the world
but despite all this acclaim and
attention
there's something the vast majority of
the series fans don't know
namely that the peaky blinders were a
real birmingham gang and that many of
the characters who've appeared in the
show's six series were real people who
terrorized the streets of britain in the
late 19th and early 20th centuries
not only that but amongst those original
peaky blinders was a criminal mastermind
who went on to form one of the biggest
gangs in all of british history and no
his name wasn't tommy shelby
though interestingly enough the person
i'm referring to does indeed show up in
the tv series i'll be very impressed if
you can guess who it is before the end
of this video this is the story of the
real peaky blinders one of the most
interesting and influential gangs in
british history now you know when you go
into a creative studio and they have
things for a project stuck up on a wall
sketches reference images ideas notes
diagrams etc well millernote is just
like that but it's entirely online and
the walls are well infinite millernote
is a place to collect and organize all
of your thoughts and ideas put together
checklists of everything that needs to
get done and visualize and gather
inspiration and when you're ready to
share your work you can invite your
colleagues and clients gather important
feedback and collaborate with them in
real time and starting a project is easy
with over 100 built-in templates
available for designers photographers
filmmakers and more i'm currently using
miller notes upon a new video about
whether it's possible to build a
real-life death star i particularly
enjoy being able to easily add other
videos i find around the web for
inspiration when we're working on a new
video for the channel it can often be
difficult to visualize how the script
and visuals are going to come together
that's where miller note has helped me
so much in the future i plan to use
miller note for our most difficult video
projects so i can easily get that bird's
eye view finally miller note is
available for free with no time limit so
sign up using the link in the
description and start your next creative
project almost 200 years ago in 1833 an
active parliament was passed that
regulated the work of children under the
age of 13 in british factories for the
first time in history whilst making it
illegal for kids to work in factories
was clearly a good thing the act had
some unexpected consequences at the time
children provided an important source of
income to britain's poorest families
so when an entire generation of those
children were essentially made redundant
overnight two things happened hundreds
of thousands of families already on the
breadline became that much poorer and
millions of youths suddenly found
themselves with a lot more time on their
hands
add that to the fact that times were
pretty tough in general average life
expectancy amongst the working classes
was under 45 and many people
particularly in the cities lived in
little more than slums and perhaps it's
inevitable that the 19th century saw a
sharp increase in petty crime
particularly amongst the youth
and with that increase in crime came
something britain had never really seen
before
gang culture as you probably already
guessed one of the very first such gangs
were birmingham's very own peaky
blinders he rose to prominence sometime
in the early 1880s rather than in the
1920s as is suggested in the tv show why
exactly the series writer and creator
stephen knight chose to shift the
timeline a few decades
isn't known but what is known is what
inspired him to create a show about the
peaky blinders in the first place it
turns out he's related to some of them
knight's great uncle on his father's
side was the head of a prominent peaky
blinder family called the sheldons a
name knight eventually gave in a
slightly modified form to his tv series
protagonists the show charts the rise of
the fictional shelby family to the
status of veritable crime lords but in
reality the exploits of the real peaky
blinders weren't quite so grand
take this chap for example a peaky
blinder known as harry babyface fowls
who was born in the late 1800s and
joined the gang as a teenager
despite having an absolutely textbook
gangster name
this particular mug shot was taken when
old babyface was arrested for the
heinous crime of stealing the bicycle
not exactly homicide is it
for the most part the real peaky
blinders were just a group of men and
boys stealing whatever they could to
make ends meet and fighting small-scale
battles on the streets of birmingham
those battles were often decided with
fists alone but the peaky blinders also
used a range of dangerous if somewhat
unsophisticated weapons
knives and knuckle dusters were common
and guns were used on occasion
though they were expensive and therefore
relatively rare for the most part the
peakys pretty much just used whatever
they had to hand
belt buckle seems to have been a popular
one for example as were steel-capped
boots whilst i'm on the subject of using
items of clothing in a fight i should
point out that the gang's famous hats
were actually completely harmless
in case you haven't seen the show the
story goes that gang members had razor
blades in the peaks of their caps which
they then used to slash at the foreheads
of their enemies causing blood to run
into their eyes and blind them hence
peaky blinders
in reality disposable razors hadn't
actually been invented when the peaky
blinders first appeared on the scene
they weren't produced in the uk until
1908 so sadly we can't add tommy shelby
and co to the extremely niche list of
people who weaponized their hats
alongside odd job from goldfinger and
no actually i think that's it
there are several competing theories as
to where the name really came from
carl chin a birmingham historian and
great grandson of original peaky blinder
edward derrick believes the peaky
portion of the name did indeed come from
the caps worn by the gang but that the
blinder bit was simply a piece of
birmingham slang meaning well-dressed
and that does seem to fit with what we
know about them as i've already
mentioned peaky blinder style has caught
on in a big way in the uk off the back
of the tv series but fashion was also an
extremely important part of the original
peaky blinders identities as well gang
members would spend extravagant sums on
bespoke tailoring fancy overcoats and
silk scarves
something that really stands out in many
of the surviving mug shots that
chronicle peaky blinder arrests over the
years it was kind of an unofficial
uniform if you like that made gang
members easy to identify on the streets
of birmingham the distinctive hairstyle
that shows up in the tv series shaved
sides and a mop of hair on top is also
based on a real trend amongst the peaky
blinders
though if anything the genuine article
was even more outlandish with only the
fringe left unshaved a bit like that
monstrosity sported by brazilian legend
ronaldo during the 2002 world cup
anyway the peaky blinders a term which
eventually became the collective name
for dozens of different street gangs in
birmingham continued to grow during the
latter part of the 19th century and the
bigger they got the more of a problem
they became as well as the regular
muggings and burglaries turf war sprung
up between rival gangs looking to expand
their territory often into more affluent
parts of the city where the pickings
were quite literally richer clashes
between peaky blinders and the police
became relatively common and in 1897 the
situation came to a head when a police
constable by the name of george snipe
was murdered during a battle with a
group of gang members the incident was a
key moment in the evolution of
birmingham's gangs the crossing of an
invisible line the peaky blinders could
no longer be considered a nuisance
nor were they solely a problem within
birmingham's slums something had to be
done
and that something as it happens went by
the name of charles rafter
a decorated northern irish police chief
future knight of the british empire and
certified hard bastard rafter was tasked
with cleaning up the streets of
birmingham
and that meant dealing with the peaky
blinders once and for all
he hired several hundred new police
officers all of whom were at least five
foot ten and handy with their fists
510 might not sound all that impressive
by modern standards but it was
positively enormous in 1900 when the
average adult man stood at little more
than five foot five
by the way if a hard-nosed northern
irish copper being sent into birmingham
to deal with the peaky blinders is
ringing a few bells that'll be because
it's pretty much exactly what happens in
the first couple of series of the tv
show stephen knight has never publicly
confirmed that sam neil's character
inspector campbell
was based on rafter but the similarities
are hard to ignore
whatever the truth rafter's method soon
began to pay dividends
he used his growing army of giant
brawlers and police uniforms to
overpower the local gangs and within 10
years or so the peaky blinders had all
but ceased to exist
but our story isn't over just yet
because not all the peaky blinders were
quite so ready to hang up their knuckle
dusters and as birmingham's somewhat
disorganized gang scene crumbled into
rafters iron grip
one young hard man saw an opportunity to
fill that void with a brand new crime
wave of a rather more organized variety
his name was billy kimber if you're a
fan of the show you'll know him as the
leader of the birmingham boys and tommy
shelby's first major rival in the series
but whilst the real william kimber was
indeed the head honcho of the birmingham
boys you might be surprised to learn
that he actually started out life as a
peaky blinder from the mean streets of
birmingham in the show he's portrayed as
a londoner not only that but there's
plenty of similarities between billy
kimber's real rise to power and tommy
shelby's fictional one
under kimber's leadership the birmingham
boys grew to become one of britain's
first genuine organized crime empires
focusing mainly on illegal butt making
and extortion much like tommy shelby did
with his peaky blinders billy kimber
quickly pushed the boundaries of his
empire
far beyond birmingham eventually taking
over race courses across most of central
and northern england
by the early 1920s kimber was very
probably the most powerful gangster in
britain but there was one area of the
country his influence didn't yet reach
london
just like tommy shelby kimber was an
insatiably ambitious man
and so in 1921 he decided to make his
move on the capital the birmingham boys
went after the bookmakers of london
using intimidation tactics in an attempt
to wrestle control of the lucrative
racecourses that can be found in and
around the city it was going pretty well
too
until one of kimber's men picked on the
wrong bookmaker alfie solomon
again that name's going to be familiar
to fans of the show
though the real alfie solomon an s was
added to the character's name for the
show
wasn't quite the major crime lord he's
portrayed as on tv by tom hardy though
he did have strong ties to london's
jewish gangs
anyway to cut a long story short
kimber's goons beat seven shades of [ __ ]
out of poor old alfie solomon
leaving him with lacerations across his
face and several missing teeth
solomon was incensed obviously and he
took his grievance against the
birmingham boys to the so-called
godfather of the east end a jewish
gangster by the name of edward emanuel
solomon convinced emanuel that the
birmingham boys were a threat and
emmanuel used his prodigious influence
to set legendary english italian mob
boss charles darby sabini another
prominent character in the tv show and
london's racecourse kingpin against
billy kimber
after several large-scale skirmishes the
first gang wars to make national
headlines in britain
sabini eventually emerged victorious
regaining control of the london
racecourse scene kimber was allowed to
keep his tracks in the midlands and the
north but it's rumored he eventually
made his way to america where he worked
for none other than al capone though
details of his activities there are a
little sketchy what we do know is that
he lived out his later years in england
where he left behind his criminal past
to become a legitimate bookmaker dying a
wealthy man at 63 which was pretty good
going at the time in many ways the tv
show is a romanticized grandiose
reimagining of what stupid blinders
might have been had things turned out a
little differently an alternate history
that melds the lives of some of
britain's most infamous forgotten
criminals with the fictional story of
tommy shelby and his family
and whilst the real peaky blinders may
never have risen to the heights of their
fictional counterparts
they present a fascinating and sadly
often overlooked period in british
history thanks for watching